the other element to all of these
conspiracies that we're talking about
day after day after day is the fact that
republican
congress women and men are whipping
their their constituencies into a frenzy
last night
in williamson county tennessee which is
just miles north of nashville
there was a school board meeting
and at this school board meeting they
had medical experts testify
about
their agreement with their support of
children wearing masks in school
i'm going to read from this charlotte
observer article about the melee that
took place and i'm going to play a clip
of it it is
saddening i mean really there's no other
there's no other adjective it is it is
it is a sickening moment in american
history right now that we're all living
through watching the mismanagement of
this health crisis at the hands of the
republicans governors all over the state
and then also your local municipalities
this charlotte observer article
anti-massacres threaten experts over
mandate in tennessee schools
we will find you
the two-minute clip two-minute clip i'm
getting ready to play posted on twitter
by journalist matt masters was recorded
at the williamson county administration
complex in franklin tennessee after the
school board voted in favor of a
temporary mass mandate amid rising covet
19 cases
williamson county is just south of
nashville sorry i said north
hundreds attended the nearly four-hour
meeting where 30 people were allowed to
speak
wkrn reported
all of this
the board ultimately passed the measure
in a 7-3 vote
under the new rule all elementary school
students staff and visitors will be
required to wear a face covering inside
and on buses
starting thursday
a notice on the williamson county
website states the mandate expires
september 21
11 59 pm so it is a brief
temporary
order to wear a mask
it's not installing an iron lung and
sticking your kid in it it's a piece of
cloth over your face that mitigates the
transmission of a deadly virus
watch this moment from these maniacs
[Applause]
[Music]
they are stalking a health official
through the parking lot telling him to
take his mask off
screaming at him we will not comply
it's a mask
it gets worse
they track around the side of the car
and they start accosting someone in
their vehicle with their window rolled
up
the same knucklehead in the t-shirts
sad day
in america
cops there doing nothing
[Music]
what is getting ready to take place is
an alarming thing because it's the
person who is trying to act as though
they're reasonable
keep it calm we want peace we want peace
who immediately starts parroting the
same rhetoric as t-shirt guy here
turning to the person in the car
explaining to them we know who you are
we will find you
no no they're not you're not
you will never be allowed in public
again we know who you are you can leave
freely but we know who you are we will
find you and then this
you'll never be able to be in public
again
the same people who were
very likely
outraged that a man approached tucker
carlson in a fish and tackle shop and
said something to him peacefully
this is a melee this is on the verge of
violence so much so that there has to be
cops planted constantly throughout the
crowd all over the place watch how this
the rest of this unfolds
you never let it be a lot of public
again yes
i know who you are let them out let's
spread them out
[Applause]
whoa you better watch it
keep it coming
keep it calm everybody back up please
everybody back up
back up back up
i'm back man i'm on your side
back up
i'm a parent
wonderful example setting for children
the parents
[Music]
[Applause]
fantastic
fantastic
this is
a melee
it is this kind of thought it's this
kind of behavior that led
and i don't think it's a stretch i don't
think it's a reach to draw a line
between this type of a lack of adherence
to science and research and data
and and instead
um a belief in conspiracy theories
i don't think it's it's it's untoward to
to link that to the insurrection that
took place
it is a frame of mind
all of this is taking place these
hundreds of people screaming and wailing
and gnashing of teeth
over trying to keep kids safe
over wearing a piece of cloth
over their faces
inexplicable